Buenas tardes Walter Ayala ex ministro
de defensa de Pedro Castillo ha señalado
que se ha impuesto este recurso legal
ante la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos porque según los
abogados de Castillo la justicia peruana
se demora en atender los recursos de
Amparo a favor del ex gobernante En ese
sentido allá le ha dicho que en las
próximas horas se tendrá novedades al
respecto precisamente el Primer Ministro
peruano Alberto
estuvo advirtiendo hace poco
al congreso de este país también como la
fiscalía de que se acelere el
procesamiento de cargos contra Pedro
Castillo porque el Primer Ministro
tarola dejó entrever que es el
expresidente Castillo estaría siendo
asesorado por Abogados del presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro quien hace unos
años interpuso una medida cautelar ante
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos para poder ser repuesto en su
cargo de alcalde de Bogotá cuando fue
destituido Pues bien precisamente Pedro
Castillo ha usado esta misma estrategia
y el anuncio de esta acción legal ante
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos coincide precisamente cuando la
fiscalía ha formalizado la investigación
contra Pedro Castillo por los presuntos
delitos de organización criminal tráfico
de influencias y colusión y no solamente
eso la fiscalía peruana también se está
preparando para pedir ante la justicia
una prisión preventiva contra Pedro
Castillo que podría ir de 18 a 36 meses
precisamente por estos últimos cargos
que está haciendo investigado por la
fiscalía peruana vamos a ver cómo se
desenvuelve esta situación pero algunos
expertos jurídicos están diciendo que
debido al éxito que tuvo el presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro Pedro Castillo
también podría correr el mismo destino
siendo favorecido por el organismo
internacional